I believe there's a hero no gives us
strength makes us Noble even though
sometimes we have to give up the thing
we want the most grace declining you
always appear exhausted
I know I'm trying where you been pal you
don't return my calls I've been kind of
busy taking pictures of your friend
spider-man killed my father no matter
what I do do you love me or not no
matter how hard I try I'm spider-man
dead it's the ones I love who will
always be the ones who pay spider-man I
let things get in the way before there
was something I thought I had to do I
don't have to I like staying here
tonight theater
now on to the main event TVs he's gonna
put Oscorp on the map
my father never even dreamed
crazy sunny it just turns himself into
some kind of a monster for mechanical
arms welded right onto his body
we take spider-man's pictures where is
he secretly off your loyalty to
spider-man not your best friend
[Music]
to me how do I find them Peter Parker
fine spider-man
I'll peel the flesh of our boss
there are bigger things happening here
they mean you
[Music]
behind the mask
[Music]